his life here on the show it's one of my
folks that we are done giving away
copies robot biscuit and Jet Li 333 are
the winners of our final two combo oh
thank you very much to everyone remember
to follow us on at gamespot on twitter
if you want to win prizes every week on
the lobby Peter bran hello this is seth
park and the stick of truth nice
actually watching an episode of the show
cuz i can tell the difference I'll never
tell what's going on with this video
game I'm in a fight so this is an RPG
from obsidian and it is very much like
an interactive south park episode you
can't really tell right now but when I'm
running around the world it really does
feel genuine so this is a the Orion
you're in a bottle here this is very
much a turn based role-playing game fair
going on here yeah turn-based battle um
you know these kids had their made-up
world and I'm finding the elves as it
were and but essentially I mean for me
I'm so interested in the world of this
game just exploring South Park is
everything is here a shity wok of shitty
sushi I'm sorry citywalk shitty sushi
yes city shooting sir that's only one
the coolest things is how this game
literally takes off from like the last
episode yes season and continue so if
you know if you remember from the
episode city shoe city sushi shitty
sushi it's burned down its it in the end
of the episode it got smashed oblivion
and they have that there and you walk by
me and takes off exactly where the
season was I saw the M asked us a fire
to a trailer as well all right side the
cinema open the billboard is this is
lots of in joke ESET product nonsense
going on here mr. Brian oh yeah no dude
yeah there's there's so much I'm sorry
I'm knee-deep in tweaked you know yeah
yeah looking at what class are you I'm
the fighter okay um so you have the
fighter there's a magician I believe may
be a mage and something else and then
the Jew did you which is actually a
pretty fun class to play I was playing a
different a different save file with
that character the yeah I don't know
said I know that dudes on his phone I'm
his wife is just looking at him like you
pieces you gonna get people in here as
well you get so yeah you have a bunch of
different piles you can use throughout
this game and it him hit people Oh
you can you know you're running the
characters like Cartman's mom is just
sitting on the couch you can go up and
hit her if you want obviously there's so
many things that are interactive here
that sort of plan to the whole notion
that you know you re your participate
let's jump oh come on back there oh my
god should pokemon i love them is that
shoe please be sure I can't get it um
got to buy them get again on pogo Oh
lamb door is my favorite if you have any
questions at all for Peter about Seth
park and stick of truth please by all
means ask gamespot on twitter in the
twitch chat or on the comments and i'll
make sure i passed upon it's a facebook
uh yeah so this whole the whole menu
system is sort of has this social
network structure where everyone you
meet actually becomes your friend ok you
get updates from them throughout the
game net worth 16 x 55 cents do you buy
items in this game very much ah well you
can this game is not very difficult ok
it's pretty straightforward and simple
as long as you don't screw around too
much like if you're used to playing
really challenging hardcore RPGs this is
not going to tax you at all you'll have
a really easy time getting through it
yeah but it's so much fun I mean there's
every everybody I wish I could hear what
she was saying a little better but ok
wait sir comes a battle who these kids
are strewn about town shot yeah it's got
a mechanic that's very similar to the
Super Mario RPG series ok I'll show you
right now so if I just go to attack my
character is going to flash and I'll
Nate I'll note that his name is
douchebag ok I don't want to self um yes
confirmed you have the option to name
your character and whether I named him
that or not I will leave up to the users
although they can probably guess so
Peter bride named his character
douchebag yeah everyone's clear you were
in titles throughout the game know so
that that does change how Lanier is this
is it do you have to take the story
missions in a very particular order or
is there a much slide quite stuff going
on here it's fairly linear like right
now I'm at a point where I've to meet to
get tweaked and token I think and I can
choose to pick up either one of them but
actually I was able to move about and
pick up a random side quest that didn't
have me going around the world very much
but yeah you don't have to do like step
a step b step c
and I love that because drop the ball
and hit him with a bat like it as a
question here from Moomin how much of
the game has been banned in Europe Rob
are you putting together some sort of a
you went through a lot of the footage of
this game yeah a lot of that sort of
stuff there were I believe two moments
that were banned one was a abortion
minigame oh my boot that were two and
fortunately I really wanted to get my
hands on that one and then a I think the
anal probing seen Wyman's why and then I
think in Germany they you know Germany
they have like an anti swastika and you
know historical they try to like pull
back and all that I took unfortunate
stuff that happened so they wait War two
yeah they basically like wiped out all
the swats cos and all that stuff they
replace it with anything I wonder I
don't know if they were actually I had
seen ya kittens at rival TV asks what
type of abilities did do the Jew have um
mr. Brian he's got to make some physical
attacks and magical abilities there's
one in particular did I see him use a
dreidel and it was just listed in the
inventory as do thing probably yeah
there's this sling of David yeah well
there's one move called the circumcised
yes right hmm it's a little bloody can
you play as a female character no
possible really no I don't believe so
just make a little dude I can be wrong
about that but I mean I just I chose the
meal they leave it pretty open-ended for
the most part like you just either
called douchebag or you know commander
douchebag no but I didn't notice
anything as far as that as well gender
role can um when you start are you the
silent protagonist thing going on where
you never talk and then right everyone
else fills in lines for yeah yeah yeah
these are gender or not gender neutral
parents it's great hey mrs. 21st century
brought europe uh know that your parents
are sort of like nondescript origin i
think that like they they fit any race
essentially are the loading things just
random loading time I saw the goth kid
they're not another like
they are okay so up here I think I need
to distract these guys by hitting them
they're out of range I really want to
find a toilet um let me know my Barbrady
hmm Tonioli replace down Barbrady with
that redheaded cop in the series that
kind of got over oh wait how many phones
you have I know you should hold that
another phone yeah yeah on people of
South Park they're plugged in 0 and fast
travel is Timmy with a wagon strapped to
a chair it's just make an awesome it has
this great leg I'm all right wow this is
great horse sound effect I'm gonna
off-screen like a stuffed horse just
sort of like tape to his carriage is
Jimmy Ennis there's David yeah David
looking good wait i never knew she
worked anywhere what does she work with
David Hasselhoff's fan club or something
you know it's funny today's rhinoplasty
that was like never touched on I think
maybe there's like an early episode
where they showed Stan's mom working at
the rhinoplasty but poor makeup haha oh
yeah so you can change your appearance
throughout the game with these little
add-ons they do nothing for your stats
yeah yeah only see which ones I have
right now actually nothing whatsoever
there's only like buffs or oh I thought
I had balls on chin Toby balls on chin
oh jin bold seemed to ball boy then I
don't have them his lemmiwinks in this
video game I was gonna name characters
NOS deficit into your game no I
definitely know that there is a moment
where you go up um mr. slave's anus
second poll hey man sometimes it's the
first hole hmm oh god I can't afford me
rhinoplasty yeah even have a personal
problem yeah it's true actually no he
hasn't I like that photo on the back
left please just having some of the vase
David hospital of course here's how big
is the world have I have biggest south
park oh let me show you thanks look
Danny come on menu the menu takes a
little bit of time to come up you're
playing this on the xbox 360 or 36 this
is ad on pc and playstation 3 as while I
was not right yeah you're looking at the
entirety of the map here okay um you
know not too small not too big either
start
and add you do a lot of them like
farming dudes in this game for abilities
do you level up in that manner or is it
more of the items you have yeah no you
tell you level up is answer your
questions are you gonna hit this girl of
course you're such a juror that bird is
there any forsett benefits to that
whatsoever well sometimes you can knock
items out of trees and pick those up um
that's the one thing that's cool I don't
have the key to that oh can you show the
force have you done the force yet no I
don't have that the force being the you
fired in your hand and then throw it at
someone oh I definitely had all these
houses are locked [ __ ] what's in there
but Betty Donovan in loving memory of
Betty's he dunivan I don't know what
that is oh you're just the worst all
these houses man so if you're the thief
can you break into those that's a good
question I mean so it is thanks a lot of
houses are just unlocked by default and
you can go into like every room in the
house which is pretty cool sometimes you
see things that you really wish you
hadn't seen oh here we go Jamie's house
I saw a sign for Timmy outside oh please
die BTW no no no that was that's like
the the station where Tim he comes to
pics okay okay we need to go out next
then so where are we here nondescript
character oh no this is that kid who has
the he's obsessed with the Star Trek oh
he's the Spock kid yeah yeah yeah I'm
Star Trek
the is most of the exchanges in this
just random like talking is there any
benefit to you and looks like West this
way at all yeah I mean there are a
couple side quests like so for example I
ran into an alleyway of the day and
there were a couple kids picking on a
girl okay I basically beat them I think
she gave me like a little bit of a
reward all right um but you know it's
it's really just about interacting with
everything like the gameplay here is is
so simple and straightforward I don't
want to say it feels tacked on Jesus I
mean it's the game right it's not just
like you're exploring south park but
that really is the best part of it is
just going around talking to people
hearing things that you would expect or
perhaps not expect them say I'm waiting
to see you like you walk in the room is
on the talk what you doing yeah this is
awesome you gotta take hahaha oh she is
so [ __ ] oh [ __ ] yeah you guys nicely
said she goes another one yeah what
happy to tap so fast what come on man
yeah everyone poops hahaha Jill writer
you feel lighter yeah together let's get
a little stamina buff there you pick up
everything this game i crumpled paper
don't you take the poo out of toilet
wait what yeah okay no oh [ __ ]
Meredith's pocket it now it's my [ __ ]
I'm gonna take a shower meet it for a
buff this game well I'm shower I think
you can use it to throw at someone
pretty sure oh I'm just equip it oh we
find al gore and throw it at him I want
to throw poo and I boys face through
how's this for an inconvenient truth
inconvenient poop and convenient poop
come on cursor they were gonna do it no
you can't equip it there oh you can't
stick it on the end of your arrows a lot
thief maybe it's just a look at and just
you know enjoy reminisced a boil
experiences to have him to hold Peter
kind of do dystopia water stuck in the
bathroom there's a drought going on all
right I want you to have a look i want
to see Timmy and then let's call it a
day oh yeah I will be able to call it
let's say I can call him but he really
only appears that first time oh man do
want to see what he's up to in the
social yes I do but the phone
what's also great is you'll see like
chat or like replies on its own like
someone will apply to like Kenny who
says like I'm a princess or something
like that ok ok around a shadow yeah it
just random stuff you'll catch that they
like continued throughout the game oh
alright that's not happening sorry so
that's why didn't hit earlier I want you
to throw dudes hit somebody out here
we're gonna wear somebody wears somebody
wears somebody truck holt all right
don't worry about her get in for more on
South Park and the stick of the truth